Now remember,
Central Asia was under Soviet rule for
many decades,
and before that it was part of the
czarist empire.
This is an area of many different ethnic
groups.
The Uzbeks,
the Tajiks,
the Kazaks,
the Kyrgies,
and to some degree,
the territory is that these groups
inhabited would never really clearly
demarcated there.
They're nomadic people,
so they have traditional lands.
But the Zaras came in and said,
okay,
this is where we're going to draw the
lines.
And then the Soviets came in and drew
the lines and they don't really bear
close approximation to where the
particular people lived.
So there are a lot of competing claims
to wear.
Their territory should be,
and in these areas lie uranium,
lie natural gas and coal and oil.
So there are some struggles underway as
to who should control what of these
valuable areas.
So you could have fights in the future
that a territorial over,
you know,
who should get these prized areas.
Now on top of that,
you have a situation where most of the
governments in these areas are
controlled by people who were once part
of the Soviet bureaucratic machine.
You know,
they,
they look and smell like old sue Soviet
bureaucrats.
Right.
And they're,
they're not,
you know,
they claim to be Democrats,
but they're really not.
They're,
they're really very authoritarian.
And with the new wealth coming from oil
and natural gas,
well most of that money winds up in the
hands of their friends and relatives and
cronies and a lot of of the wealth
disappears into hidden bank account
somewhere.
Uh,
you know,
I'm thinking particularly of the family
of Nursultan Nazarbayev,
the president of Kazakhstan,
which is the wealthiest of these
countries.
Meanwhile,
most of the people in these countries
are not getting any wealthier since the
breakup of the Soviet Union.
These are also predominantly Muslim
countries.
They have been a target of the,
of the Muslim Islamic fundamentalist
movements of the past decade or so.
I'm talking of groups associated with
Osama bin Laden and al Qaeda and some of
the other extremist movements that we've
heard of.
And these groups are finding some
sympathy among the people of these areas
who the governments to be corrupt,
to be insensitive to their needs,
to be pocketing all the money and giving
it to their cronies.
So in the future you could have
uprisings,
like the kind,
we've had another countries that are
fueled by Islamic propaganda,
but really at heart are about the
Maldistribution of resource wealth.
You know,
kind of like what I was talking about in
the Niger Delta area where the elites
claim all of the resource wealth
conditions are deteriorating,
the masses of the people are getting
worse off,
not better conditions,
a deteriorating.
And this is exactly the kind of fertile
atmosphere in which extremist movements
take off.
And,
and this is what I worry about.
This is an area of geopolitical
competition between three great powers.
This is the one part of the globe in
which the United States,
Russia and China are all competing for
influence.
At the same time,
the United States,
after the breakup of the Soviet Union
saw this is an area to gain geopolitical
advantage and new sources of energy.
So first President Clinton and now
President Bush have made an all out
effort to gain influence in the stands
is they're called Kazakhstan,
Uzbekistan,
Turkmenistan and Tajikistan Kyrgyzstan
if I get them all right,
but Russia which used to control this
area under the Soviets and before that
the tsars also wants to control this
area.
But now you have a third factor in here,
China,
which is very worried about instability
and its back door.
The Chinese region of Shen Jiang,
which has a Muslim majority area and
it's extreme west and it's the one part
of China that's predominantly Muslim.
They are very worried about instability
in this area.
So it wants to have a say in what goes
on in Central Asia and it has growing
economic interests in this area.
Also wants to tap into the,
the resource riches of Central Asia has
also become involved.
So you have three great powers all
seeking geopolitical influence it once
the United States is providing military
aid,
Russia is providing military aid and now
China has stepped in,
collaborating often with Russia through
a new organization known as the Shanghai
Cooperation Organization or the SCO.
And the Seo pr jointly with,
you know,
China and Russia together provide
military aid to the stands.
If this isn't enough,
both United States and Russia have
established military bases in the
region,
namely and Kyrgyzstan.
You have about 50 miles apart,
a US base on one side of Bishkek,
the Capitol of Kyrgyzstan and a Russian
base.
On the other side.
I mentioned all of this because you have
to imagine a situation in the future
where there's some kind of upheaval and
Kyrgyzstan between,
you know,
one political faction against the other.
The military breaks apart and somehow or
another American soldiers and Russian
soldiers get caught up in the conflict
and overnight
have shooting.